I have a map ish brain there's something
in my head that gets very happy when I
look at mouths some would call David
Rumsey a Carta file others just put it
more bluntly he's obsessed
later in my life the collecting gene as
we call it flipped on sometime in my 30s
and runs his collecting gene is strong
over 30 years he's accumulated more than
150 thousand maps which he kept in his
San Francisco home many of the maps and
cartographical artifacts are centuries
old I began to see maps as not just
wayfinding devices but wayfinding back
into history and that's when this whole
collection was born I began to see them
as stories of historical events of
scientific progress of survey even of
art now he's donated his massive
collection to Stanford University part
of the philosophy of the center is to
make it as open and inviting as possible
to undergraduates so that they can get
the same bug that I've had for maps the
new map Center is meant to be the bridge
between classic mapping and modern
cartography visitors will be able to see
things like atlases that show Paris
through the ages and then use the
wall-sized screen to compare the details
of pairs of geo-reference maps from
those different historical periods you
end up having the old map inherit the
latitude and longitude of the cart and a
surface and once you do that with
several of these maps then you're able
to layer them one on top of the other
and then start looking at the changes or
time the key to having that modern
access is the obsessive scanning and geo
referencing Stanford has a 16 megapixel
phase one scan back machine that shoots
high detail high resolution images of
massive maps so far the Stanford digital
repository has scanned 67,000 maps and
each has a permanent URL that can be
downloaded by anyone from anywhere in
the world just endless hidden stories in
these maps they have to be teased out
we're going to provide as many tools as
we can to do that process but what we
hope happens is that a lot of our users
teach us how they can find things and
use methods that we're not even aware of